[Musik]
hier lieben heute gibt es ein ganz
besonderes rezept wir machen nämlich
einen wolken kuchen
ich glaube der strawberry cloud fähig
ist bekannt ein amerika in deutschland
aber seht mal zeit dass wir den hier
fleißig nachmachen und zwar ist das ein
kuchen der wirklich wie erdbeer wolken
schmeckt also extrem leicht und das
ganze ist no baic das heißt wir tun
ihnen gleich einfach in die
tiefkühltruhe und dann ist auch schon
fertig also super schnell gezaubert
ich mache jetzt erstmal den novellen und
dafür habe ich hier einmal butterkekse
ich geb dir alles gleich in einen mixer
also mutter kind habe ich irgendwas
glocken kokosraspeln und weiche butter
beziehungsweise flüssige butter die habe
ich aber leicht abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt gibt ihr den klicks boden ganz
einfach in eine springform mit 26 cm
durchmesser und runter gern ein
backpapier legen und richtig schön fest
andrücken
das kommt jetzt erst mal zur seite und
wir machen jetzt die leckere wolken
füllung die ist wirklich extrem lecker
und ich zeige euch jetzt die zutaten ich
habe hier ein mal erdbeeren ihr nehmt
gerne zu erdbeersaison auch frische
erdbeeren ist ja witzig tiefkühl
variante und habe so schön auftauen
lassen und abtropfen lassen
dann habe ich ihn natürlich zucker für
die süße für den geschmack ganz ganz
wichtig vanille extrakt verlinke ich
euch den infobox und spritzer
zitronensaft und dann haben wir eine
zutat da werdet ihr bestimmt ganz viel
in die kommentare schreiben
wir haben nämlich besser gesagt er weiß
wir brauchen die rose weist wenn das ein
mega frisch ist ist es natürlich auch
gar kein problem
es sei denn ihr seid jetzt schwanger
oder hat mir allergie dann müsst ihr das
rezept zu kippen oder wenn ihr das nicht
möchte dann habe ich leider keine
alternative für euch weil wir das ganze
natürlich gleich in die tiefkühltruhe
legen und ihr werdet sich bereuen es
schmeckt extrem fluffig und lecker und
ich werde jetzt erstmal die eier trennen
das ist ganz wichtig ist in die sauber
trennt und das eigelb nämlich später für
rührei oder filme in köln gibt es ja
auch tausend möglichkeiten
[Musik]
so der nächste stop ist jetzt total
einfach gegeben zum teil weiß wenn ihr
möchtet eine prise salz behebt den süßen
geschmack dann natürlich zucker außerdem
zitronensaft vanille extrakt und die
erdbeeren jetzt bestenfalls total weich
sind weil sie eben auf zimmertemperatur
sind und danach müssten wir das ganze
bis hinweise während dessen maximale
stufe fünf minuten ihr welt erst nach 23
minuten denken hey was ist das denn
das wird ihr gar nicht stark aber nach
fünf minuten richtig flüssig und ich
zeig euch das ergebnis jetzt noch mal
aus der nähe
das ist der inbegriff von flüssigkeit
und diese masse schmeckt genauso wie sie
aussieht sie schmeckt genauso wie sie
aussieht total locker leicht ich auch
ich wüsste ich immer darauf an nächsten
so eine gesichtsmaske machen so toll
sieht das aus so richtige fantasien mit
dieser masse sind geben wir das einfach
auf den keks boden verteilen das und
dann ihr glaubt es kaum aber dann sind
wir eigentlich schon fertig richtig
krass wie schnell das ging heftig
und jetzt habe ich die creme in meine
springform gegeben und oben nicht glatt
gestrichen sondern halt wolken mäßig so
ein bisschen unregelmäßig persönlich
finde dass schüler und ihr könnt
natürlich machen was ihr zuhause gerne
machen möchte
aber denk dran obendrüber kommt gleich
noch eine leckere erdbeeren sie zeige
ich euch jetzt im schnelldurchlauf weil
die echte idee ist einfach tiefgekühlte
erdbeeren müsste gar nicht auftauen
lassen oder frische wenn ihr saison habt
und dann gibt er da ein bisschen zucker
mit dazu einmal aufkochen lassen gerne
noch mal durch ein sieb geben damit ihr
die kirche nicht drin habt und dann habt
ihr fertige erdbeer so so einfach geht
das lässt einfach abkühlt und dann könnt
ihr euch den kühlschrank aufbewahren
die hier kommt jetzt übrigens in die
tiefkühltruhe acht stunden seid mir
nicht böse aber acht stunden ist seit
diese geniale torte jetzt braucht und
ihr könnt das natürlich am vortag
vorbereiten und in der kühltruhe hätte
sich bis zu sechs wochen also ihr habt
immer was da wir immer gesucht da ist
oder wenn ich selber lust drauf habt
könnt ihr euch da immer ein stück von up
machen lasst das nur ungefähr eine halbe
stunde auf zimmertemperatur stehen dann
wird der keks boden auch noch mal schön
weich und nicht so fest und die
konsistenz ist einfach extrem lecker
macht diese torte unbedingt nach freue
mich über eure fotos ich freue mich wenn
ihr diesem video in münchen nach oben da
lassen wir es euch gefallen hat
ansonsten abonniert doch main kanal
kostenlos dann verpasste hier auch
deswegen die ein rezepte wie dieses
nicht mehr und dann sehen wir uns auch
bei meinem nächsten rezept des eureka
[Musik]